CONNECTED TO RUSSIANS.
ON THAT NOTE, THIS IS NOT GOING
AWAY AS WE KNOW IT.
HAPPY NEW YEAR TO YOU GUYS,
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING.
>> HAPPY NEW YEAR.
>> Katie: HERE IS SOMETHING WE
HAVE BEEN TELLING YOU ABOUT FOR
WEEKS.
DEMOCRATS WILL BE TURNING TO
SEXUAL
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT ALLEGATIONS TO
TRY TO DUMP TRUMP NOW THAT
ALLEGATIONS OF COLLUSION WITH
RUSH ARE GOING NOWHERE.
BUT NOW THE CHATTER AND DEBATE
IS INTENSIFYING BY THE DAY.
LET'S DISCUSS THIS WITH THE
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT FOR
THE END INDEPENDENT JOURNAL
REVIEW.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.
WE APPRECIATED.
WE HAVE HEARD A LOT OF THE LAST
FEW WEEKS BUT PRESIDENT TRUMP
POTENTIALLY FIRING SPECIAL
COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS VEHEMENTLY
DENYING THAT CLAIM.
WHY DO WE KEEP HEARING ABOUT IT?
>> WHY DO WE KEEP HEARING ABOUT
THE WHITE HOUSE GOING ON THIS
RAMPAGE?
LOOK, I THINK A NUMBER OF
DEMOCRATS -- SORRY, KATIE, I
HAVE AN ECHO IN MY EAR --
DEMOCRATS CLEARLY -- I WANT TO
SEE IF THAT IS FIXED FOR YOU.
>> Katie: LITTLE TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES.
I WE FIXED?
ARE YOU ALL RIGHT?
>> I'M GOOD.
>> Katie: OKAY.
>> Katie: DO NEED TO QUESTION
LET'S GO TO 2018 AND HOW
DEMOCRATS WILL PLAY THIS.
WE'VE HEARD FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
OF THE PRESIDENT HAS NO GOALS OF
FIRING SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT
MUELLER, DESPITE THOSE CLAIMS WE
ARE HEARING THAT HE MIGHT, HOW
IS THE WHITE HOUSE REACTING TO
THAT AND WHAT ARE YOU SEEING ON
THE GROUND GOING INTO 2018 IN
TERMS OF THE STRATEGY?
>> KATIE, A LOT OF THE
DEMOCRATIC STRATEGISTS THAT I
TALKED TO DO NOT WANT TO BE
PUSHING IMPEACHMENT.
AND THAT IS BECAUSE WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE SEATS THE DEMOCRATS
NEED TO WIN IN ORDER TO FLIP THE
SENATE, THERE ARE A LOT OF SEATS
THEY NEED TO ALL THAT ARE VERY
NORTH DAKOTA, THEY ALL STILL A
COUPLE OF SEATS, ARIZONA,
TENNESSEE.
AND IMPEACHMENT IS NOT GOING TO
PLAY THERE.
THE SPECTER OF IMPEACHMENT ISN'T
GOOD.
AND INDEPENDENT VOTERS WON'T
WORK FOR THAT.
THEY WANT TO SEE DEMOCRATS
REALLY TRYING TO GO FOR THINGS
LIKE INFRASTRUCTURE AND WORKING
WITH REPUBLICANS ON SOMETHING,
WE KNOW THAT IMPEACHMENT WILL
NOT PLAY.
WE KNOW THAT MOMENTUM IS ON THE
TO THE TABLE WHEN IT COMES TO
BUT THE TAX REFORM BILL THAT
JUST PASSED IS STILL NOT VERY
POPULAR.
REPUBLICANS OBVIOUSLY ARE GOING
TO BE GOING ON A TOUR OF THE
COUNTRY TO TRY TO SELL TAX
REFORM AND DEMOCRATS HAVE HAD
THE UPPER HAND FAIR.
IT DID PAST, THERE IS GOING TO
BE SOME MOMENTUM FROM
REPUBLICANS.
MESSAGING HAS BEEN BETTER FOR
THE PAST COUPLE OF MONTHS THEN
REPUBLICANS.
BUT THEY WANT TO KEEP PUSHING
THAT MESSAGE WITH THE     THE AE
THAT MESSAGE WITH THE     THE AI
THAT MESSAGE WITH THE     THE AA
THAT MESSAGE WITH THE     THE AN
PEOPLE.
>> Katie: WHAT ABOUT THE
COUNTIES, ERIN, THE HUNDRED PLUS
COUNTIES THAT SWITCH FROM
BARACK OBAMA BLUE TO
DONALD TRUMP READ IN THE LAST
ELECTION?
SEIZING ON ISSUES LIKE THE
ECONOMY, WHERE THE MOMENTUM IS
ON THE REPUBLICAN SIDE?
AND THE RUSSIA COLLUSION
ALLEGATIONS?
>> I THINK THE BIGGEST MESSAGE
THAT YOU WILL SEE FROM DEMOCRATS
IS THAT THEY WILL SAY THAT
REPUBLICANS HAVEN'T KEPT THEIR
PROMISE, SIMPLY THAT THIS TAX
REFORM BILL WILL ADD TO THE
DEFICIT, AT A TRILLION DOLLARS
TO THE DEFICIT, AND THAT MEANS
THAT THE REPUBLICANS JUST
HAVEN'T BEEN TRUTHFUL WITH WHAT
THEY HAVE BEEN TRYING TO PUSH ON
CAPITOL HILL.
I THINK THAT IS GOING TO BE A
BIGGER MESSAGE.
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT WILL PLAY IN
PRIMARIES, SURE, IT WILL BE AN
ANIMATING CAUSE FOR DEMOCRATS
WITH THEIR PROGRESSIVE ACTIVISTS
AND WITH WOMEN, BUT I DON'T
THINK THAT IS GOING TO BE THE
BIGGEST MESSAGE OF NEXT YEAR.
THE REPUBLICANS HAVE VERY LITTLE
WIGGLE ROOM WHEN IT COMES TO
PASSING THEIR AGENDA AND THE
SENATE.
DEMOCRATS HAVE THEIR EYE SIGHT
OF THE TENNESSEE SENATE RACE,
THEY ARE GOING AFTER ARIZONA.
HOW ARE VOTERS FEELING ABOUT
2018 AND ONE OF THE BIG TOPICS
THERE?
TENNESSEE I DON'T THINK AT THE
END OF THE DAY WILL BE IN PLAY
IS TRYING TO CAST YOURSELF AS AA
IS TRYING TO CAST YOURSELF AS AD
IS TRYING TO CAST YOURSELF AS AS
IS TRYING TO CAST YOURSELF AS AE
IS TRYING TO CAST YOURSELF AS AK
IS TRYING TO CAST YOURSELF AS AS
SAYING THAT SHE WILL BE TALKING
ABOUT DONALD TRUMP AND HER
SENATE RACE.
SHE IS TRYING TO TALK ABOUT TAX
REFORM AND INFRASTRUCTURE, SOME
OF THOSE KITCHEN TABLE ECONOMIC
ISSUES, THAT'S OBVIOUSLY THE BIG
MESSAGE OF THE YEAR.
>> Katie: IT'S GOING TO BE AN